[Music]
by divine wisdom gosh
quiet shut up they have our scent run
just keep running
are you out of your mind
he's not going to make it he has to
bless the doctor protects me but define
paste look at me all the gold we want is
right
oh I just came here knowledge no breach
the seal get us through that door
all right
but my by three cup it says the blood of
the Willing good you gotta be kidding me
but what
laughter hoping he's dead all right
as shame he didn't make it
oh well chewed up gold splice about
three weeks instead of four must be had
me up somewhere
read this
but my three they come by three times I
open despite a lot of them willing hail
hail the Creator huh it hailed the
daughter
oh no no no what about the coin was it
say this is forbidden this is a
summoning I cannot speak don't lie to me
we came here thanks Ryder
what is this place I don't know maybe
maybe city or two more
[Applause]
[Music]
it's on the line fatigues
[Music]
[Music]
we call
come on open your eyes
it's not a lie protects me
there is no light here you came to the
darkness for knowledge
and all the knowledge you seek is here
surrender speak the words call her home
by 3:00 they come by 3:00 thy way opens
by the blood of the Willing we call thee
home
[Music]
Oh
create of sanctuary
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
unless her mother
save us
[Music]